the australian parliament has passed a
bill granting police powers to access
suspect's social media accounts and even
control them authorities will now be
able to modify and delete even suspects
data and hack their devices or without
having to seek a judge's approval first
they say the powers are needed though to
fight terrorism and child exploitation
much of which is conducted online but
critics stress that the new bill makes
australian police the judge the jury
even executioner while for instance in
the uk and the u.s no such powers have
been granted
at the same time there's also been
discussion about the possibility of
introducing id checks for users on
social media and dating apps australians
may be asked for instance to answer a
100 point questionnaire before setting
up an account essentially putting an end
to anonymity on the internet for many
the suggestion was also aimed at
tackling online abuse it didn't get its
way into the current bill we got some
reaction though from these uh
unprecedented powers
now being given to the police and what
was thought about them
i believe that people should be
identifiable uh relatively
quickly and relatively straightforwardly
should they do something which harms
others
things like that are always useful to
investigations and to investigative
officers because
um
communication
between individuals is usually a key
part of that investigation and
evidentially
very important
this this is clearly a police haven you
know uh police needs to do no more
uh we call it uh fascism really because
uh this is where the government is
effectively controlling the media
um in this case social media or the
internet the the source of the problem
is that social media and internet
communication
has moved on leaps and bounds and
legislation hasn't kept up with it uh
probably because legislation simply
cannot move that fast uh and
communication technology has moved
incredible speed light speed over the
last few decades
and and so
problems have arisen where
um
legitimate interests of the state
legitimate interests of the courts
legitimate interests of others have
failed to provide um
sufficient ways into internet
communications and so
that's lagged behind the times the
reality is that in
nearly all cases we are able to to
unravel the id
of people um people use email addresses
and credit cards and they pay for things
and it is nearly always possible to to
find out who they are no matter where
they are in the world and you know
this is the job of the police yes the
police will need to work a little bit
and do a little bit of digging and do a
little bit of investigation you know now
you cannot uh incriminate uh the entire
an entire nation
in practice people can be anonymous on
the internet and get up to all sorts of
criminal activity causing all sorts of
harm with the states and judicial bodies
having no practical way of getting
behind there and so
that that is the
the harm that needs to be addressed but
the balance has to be struck um
where there are sufficient safeguards um
to make sure that the police aren't
doing it um on spec as it were and
they've got proper grounds for it and so
those things do take time so it's
getting the balance right
remember the governments will take as
much power as they possibly can
um and and this is what the australian
government is doing now they are just
taking as much power as they possibly
can because they can
elsewhere ireland's data regulator has
slapped the whatsapp messaging service
with the record 225 million euro fine
for breaching eu data privacy laws that
find relates to a probe then launched in
2018 questioning the transparency of the
company's privacy policies they included
the way users data was processed and
clarity over how rules are applied on
the platform the commission calls the
violations very serious in return
facebook owned whatsapp says he
disagrees with the decision
all four infringements are in my view
very serious in nature they go to the
heart of the general principle of
transparency and the fundamental right
of the individual to protection of his
her personal data
we have worked to ensure the information
we provide is transparent and
comprehensive and will continue to do so
we disagree with the decision today
regarding the transparency we provided
to people in 2018 and the penalties are
entirely disproportionate